احمد
احنا كده يا احمد
مساء الخيرات ازي حضرتكم معلش كان ماندو
بيغششني ربنا يسعد مساكم ان شاء الله
وتكون ليله سعيده عليكم وسنه جديده سعيده
باذن الله تفصلنا عنها عده ايام وطبعا
موضوع الحلقه زي ما انا كتبت لحضراتكم انه
عام 2022 وما حمله من ازمات كبيره
واللي ما يحمله او ما قد يحمله عام 2023
اتمنى ان يحمل كل الخير انا في انتظار
اسئله حضراتكم
انا مش متاكد الصوت والصوره تمام ولا ايه
الاخبار شباب تمام
طيب
سؤال طريف في بدايه المباشر في حال فشل
الروس في اوكرانيا بشكل جذري هل يحاول
الغرب بعدها التفرغ
لدولنا المسكينه بخصنا الجزائر مصر
السعوديه التي اعتبرت في الغرب محيله
سلبيا ههه والله هو سؤال وجيه بس هم في
حال فشل الروسي اوكرانيا همم
ولا قصدك في حاله فشل الغرب في ايقاف
الروس اا انا السؤال مش واضح اذا فشل
الروس في اوكرانيا انا هتبقى همم يعني لها
سيناريو واذا فشل الغرب في مواجهه الروس
زي ما انا اعتقد ان سؤالك هيبقى مسار
مختلفه لو استاذنك يعني تعيد كتابه السؤال
افهمه اكثر السلام عليكم وعليكم السلام
شكرا جزيلا ربنا يخليكم طيب
ما مصير سوريا والله مصير سوريا
يا اخونا اسكيت مصير سوريا ده اخونا سالم
عليه
بصير سوريا يا اخويا
اخونا مرتبط
[موسيقى]
بكثير من الايرادات الدوليه يعني بصراحه
الشعب السوري ااا وده مش سري يعني لا حول
له ولا قوه
القوه الرئيسيه سواء كانت في السلطه او في
المعارضه قدرتها على تحريك الاحداث محدود
كده
ولكن المساله مرهونه بالقوه الاساسيه
الدوليه اللي هي امريكا وروسيا والقوه
الاقليميه اللي هي ايران وتركيا
وبعض الدول العربيه الى اخرهم في الوقت
الحالي الامور ما فيش اتفاق يعني في تنافر
كبير جدا اعطيك مثال واحد على هذا القدر
الكبير من التنافر انه مثلا في داخل
امريكا نفسها هم مش عارفين هم عاوزين ايه
من سوريا يعني لا هم عاوزين سلام ولا هم
قادرين على حسم او تحقيق مصالحهم بالحرب
والاسوء من كده ان هم مش عارفين ايه
بالضبط مصالحهم كل اللي هم واثقين منه حتى
الان لان هم مش متاكدين خائفين يخرجوا
فيخسروا فيفضلوا البقاء الهدف اللي واضح
بالنسبه لهم دلوقت انه
لا يجعل من الاسد رئيس قادر على انه يمارس
مهامه ولا وطبعا في نفس الوقت هم ما
عندهمش معارضه يدعموها او يقدروا يعتمدوا
عليها والهدف الاوضح ان هم يجعله من سوريا
كابوس للروس
ويسعوا لاحتواء الايرانيين والسيطره عليهم
من خلال وجودهم هم بيعملوا حاجه لا بس
يعني يكونوا قريبين من المشهد فاا يعني
عشان دي قصه تحتاج الى كلام كثير همم مصير
سوريا همم سوف يظل مرحوم بمدى توافق القوه
الكبيره على ان هم كل واحد يترضى ما دامت
التوتر موجود بين الروس والامريكان واا مع
ايران ومع تركيا والوضع في تركيا الداخلي
مؤثر جدا جدا على وضع سوريا لانه اقدر
اقول لك بلاغات انه 95% من تحركات الرئيس
اردوغان في سوريا وفي غيرها تحركه
انتخابات يونيو 2003 20
ايه هل يعقل ان يعرف كل العالم ان
اوكرانيا
طعم الاضاف روسيا وان الاوكران نفسهم لا
يعلمون واذا كانوا مدركين لذلك لماذا لا
يقفون لا يوقفون الحرب
بص يا عزيزتي نوره مين بقى هو اللي يعلم
اكيد من الاوكران هناك من يعلم بس دائما
لما بنتكلم على الشعوب
يعني المساله مش بالعدد القوه النافذه هي
اللي بتحرك الشعوب مش ممكن ان رجل اعمال
مثلا عنده عده مليارات صوته زي صوت همم
ملايين من الناس اللي هي يا دوبك بتعيش
عشان تاكل وتشرب انت عندك نخب موجوده في
اوكرانيا لها قناعات ولها مصالح
فدول حتى الان قاضوا البلاد الى هذه
المواجهه اعتقد في تقديري ان هم اخطاوا
كثيرا واي ان كانت السيناريوهات الاخرى
كانت هتبقى ارحب ببلدهم وبيهم لكن هذه
القناه عندكم على كل حال وبالتالي ما
تتكلميش على اوكرانيا اللي هي الملايين
يعني ولكن هتتكلمي على النخب اللي قاده
اوكرانيا لقرار الحرب ده واحد الحاجه
الثانيه انه في دول همم
مستفيده من الحرب او لم تمانع فيها في
اوروبا والدول ديت اللي هي خائفه جدا من
كابوس روسيا بولندا لها دور مؤثر دول
البلطجه الثلاثه لها دور مؤثر عاوزه تستغل
الحرب علشان تستنزف الروس
طبعا الولايات المتحده لكن
يظل بقى انه هل القران عندهم القدره ان هم
يغيروا ياثرو في مسار الحرب في التوقيت
الحالي صعب ممكن لما الالم يلحق بيهم
للاسف بشكل كبير جدا جائز يكون في تغيير
ما افضل الكتب باللغه الانجليزيه التي
توصي بقراءتها الى فهم واقرار السياسي
والعلاقات الدوليه هل هناك تحكم امريكا
بالخفاء اللي هم تابع لحكومه شوف بالنسبه
للكتب الانجليزيه ده سؤال جميل ده انجيل
سنو فليكس ليه سؤال جميل لانه دائما
الاصدقاء بيسالوني على كتب شرحها لهم في
السياسه او في الاقتصاد او في كذا يعني
انا للاسف وانا ما باحبش اقول القصه ديت
لان احيانا بتفهم خطا لان انا صحفي وطبعا
الناس اللي هم بيكتبوا في الصحف والكتب
يعني دول زملاء او اساتذه او يعني
او يعني كده يعني وبالتالي انا باجي اتحرك
اني اقول ان المحتوى العربي فقير جدا جدا
جدا جدا جدا جدا وبالتالي لما تقول لي
ارشح لي كتاب بالعربي انا توقفت عن
القراءه الحقيقيه بالعربي من حوالي 20 سنه
اقرا لو في استاذ لي كتب حاجه لو في زميل
مهمه كتب حاجه لكن المصادر الاساسيه
وللانصاف ده عيب في لا سمح الله في
الاساتذه اللي هم موجودين في العالم
العربي كله من اليمين الى اليسار يعني من
اقصى اليمين الاقصى اليسار لا مش مش ولكن
المستوى الحريات اللي متاحه بتخلي القدره
على الكتابه بحريه وابداع محدود بالاضافه
لعوامل ثانيه يعني انت لما تكون نسبه
الاميه في العالم العربي همم بتتكلم على
حوالي 25 ولا 30% فطبيعي وال- وبعدين ده
اللي اذن لا يقرا ولا يكتب خالص همم دي
كانت نسبه قديمه انا مش عارف زادت ولا قلت
فبتلاقي ان يعني الكتابه سلعه ما لهاش همم
ما لهاش زبون قوي باللغه اللي هي الكتب
كثيره جدا جدا جدا ولكن انا شخصيا من
انصار المدرسه الريالست او المدرسه
الواقعيه في السياسه الدوليه ولذلك انا
همم باحب اقرا للكتاب اللي هم بيكتبوا في
هذا الاتجاه اعتقد ان هم بيساعدونا لفهم
العالم بطريقه اكثر ارشح لكم فر ستارت
يعني بدايه جون مارشمر
كلمتكم عنه قبل كده وهمم في اكتر من حلقه
انا مش قادر اتذكر اسامي الحلقات جون
برشايمر همم له نظريات عظيمه جدا دافعه
عنها ولكن من لو عاوز تلخص اهم كتب يعني
في العلاقات الدوليه انه بيعتقد ان المحرك
الاساسي سلوك الدول هو الخوف بلد صف باور
ان النظريه ديت هو ما اخترع هاشم دي
موجوده من زمان لكن هو صخر ودلل عليها
بحوالي 200 سنه من دراسه التاريخ انه اللي
بيحرك دوله هو الخوف من دوله ثانيه
وبالتالي بتبتدي تستعد اا ليها للدفاع عن
نفسها الدوله الثانيه لما تشوف الدوله
هي كمان تاخذ في استعدادات وهكذا يعني ودي
قصه بدون مارشايبر جيد جدا ستيفن ام وولت
همم برده من نفس المدرسه هو استاذ فيرجن
برشامبر الاستاذ في شيء كاجو وهمم ستيفن
مول بيكتب اكتر كتابته اسلس اكتر ثلاثه
والاثنين
بالنسبه لهم كتاب عظيم جدا جدا جدا اسمه
ازريلي لابي اللوبي الاسرائيلي اتكتب اظن
في 2006 2008 حاله استثنائيه ان اثنين
اساتذه من المينسترين منسترين يعني مش
اثنين جايين من الهامش كده وعايشين مع
نفسهم دول اساتذه في الجامعات كبار
يتحدثوا بكل هذه الصراحه عن دور اللوب
الاسرائيلي المضر للولايات المتحده قبل ان
يكون مضرا بالشعوب العربيه طول فور ستارت
وفي كتابات اخرى كثيره وبالمناسبه لو انتم
عايزين مهتمين بالعلاقات الدوليه لافرار
من استخدام الاطلس والخرائط وتاثير
الجغرافيا على العلاقات الدوليه مش عاوز
اطول قوي في الاجابه لكن ده بدايتها وممكن
في الحلقات الثانيه هنتكلم على كتاب ثانيه
لهم تاثير عظيم ال امريكا لها
حكومه يعني خفيه يعني
اكيد اكيد
الحكومه الامريكيه بالمعنى اللي انت قلت
اللي هو 7 والحكومه الديب ستيب بالمعنى
اللي هو موجود في نظريات المؤامره بس
الفرق بين اللي انا بقوله والاخرين
بيقولوا مفيش حد بيجتمع في مكان مغلق
علشان يتامر على امريكا ولا على العالم
الدوله الخفيه عباره عن او الناس اللي
بيديروا القرار هم عباره عن ناس مؤثرين لم
ينتخبوا بالشعب اذا كان في امريكا او في
اي دوله اخرى هذا الكلام موجود في امريكا
هذا الكلام موجود في مصر هذا الكلام موجود
في باكستان موجود في السعوديه موجود فوق
كل دوله دول عباره عن الناس عندهم قدره
كبيره جدا على التاثير على مسار الاحداث
بس من غير ما يكونوا منتهرين من غير ما
يكونوا انتخبين ممكن نتكلم ثلاث ايام على
تاثير الناس دول وامثله في كل مكان عندهم
مصالح بيدافعوا عنها عندهم قناعات
بيدافعوا عنها وبالتالي ممكن يكون رجل
اعمال ممكن يكون مفكر ممكن يكون عسكري
ممكن يكون مصنع ممكن يكون مستورد ممكن
يكون موظف كبير عنده قناعاته وجوده بيوجه
صانع القرار
همم
مساء الخير ربنا يخليك بهاء عليكم السلام
مساء الخير اهلا يا استاذ
عبد الله باستفيد منك رغم معارضه اللي بعد
اطروحاتك والله جميله يا عبد الله كثر الف
خيرك ده معناه ان انت راجل يعني همم عقلك
واسع وبتتقبل انك تسمع لحد انت مش متفق
معه ولو قلت لي انت مش متفق معي في ايه
ممكن استفيد منك
اكيد هيستفيد منك اقصد بس اقصد اقول ممكن
اغير رايي يعني انت اقصده استاذ جبير تحيه
لك من سوريا ربنا يخليك ويحفظك
ولاء ما افضل
اسم الحركه وهي بتقول انا اسمي ولاء ربنا
طيب
اصل انا طلبت من صديقي احمد ماندو يعني
انه يقلل الفترات ما بين الاسئله بحيث ان
انا اكون قادر على القراءه يعني بهدوء من
غير معينه طيب اخونا اااه حسن
وباي حسن اهلا بك سيد تتعدد الجيوش في
السودان هل الديمقراطيه هي الحل امام
السودان بحاجه الى رجل قوي يحكم بسلطه
مركزيه دكتاتوريه
في السودان انا اسف ولا يكون في ديمقراطيه
في السودان ولا في مصر ولا في السعوديه
ولا في الجزائر ولا في تونس ما فيش يعني
الديمقراطيه ما بتتوجد شيء يعني ما فيش
قائد كده بيمنحها للناس وما فيش بلد بتدوس
على زرار تنتقل من الوضع الفوضوي او من
الوضع الديكتاتوري له الديمقراطيه
الديمقراطيه قصه
احنا تكلمنا فيها بتاخذ جهات طويل يعني
امريكا انتقلتش للديمقراطيه
بين ليله وضحاها الدول الاوروبيه عمليه
بناء الدول اخذت 200 300 سنه الدول اللي
عندها
ديمقراطيات قصيره زي مثلا المانيا احتاجت
حرب حربين عالميتين وضغوط دوليه عنيفه جدا
دمرتها عشان تتجه الى هذا الاتجاه وما
زالت هناك مقاومه زي ما شفتوا كده في
الفتره الاخيره للدوله الالمانيه بشكلها
الحرير عاوزه ثقافه مختلفه الغرب لما راحت
ديمقراطيه مثلا حدث صراع ما بين الفلاسفه
وما بين الكنيسه مش معناه ان انا ضد الدين
الكنيسه ولا المسجد بس الدين بطبعه همم
ورجال الدين عايزين همم تصورات مطلقه
للحكم
فاسقطه همم سلطه الكنيسه على سبيل المثال
همم امور كثيره تطورت فانت بتسال السودان
السودان اولا هو قد لا يعلم الكافرين ان
عنده تجربه ديموقراطيه اطول من دول عربيه
اخرى لكنه عنده عنده لعنه الجغرافيا بلد
متعدد الاطراف اعراض كثيره دوله مركزيه
ضعيفه نسبيا اا اقتصاد رغم انه عنده
فراغات طبيعيه لكن هيحتاج عشرات السنين
علشان ينعيشها وبالتالي
الحل ينزل امل في السودان الناس تتوافق
ويبداوا بس رحله البناء اللي هي همم
تستغرق سنين انا متاسف لو كان كلامي صادم
يعني السلام عليكم هل هناك تعويم جنيه
للج- للجنيه اثار العراقيه طب ساره
العراقيه ده لقب ولا مصريه انت مهتميه
بالجنيه المصري ايوه هيكون في تعويم جديده
هيكون فيه تعويم جنيه للجديد همم تعويم
جدا للجنيه لا شك فيه هذا دلوقت سعر
الجنيه اللي هو همم العادل من وجهه نظر
بعض الاقتصاديين في حدود مثلا من 25 ل 27
جنيه السعر اللي بيتداول في السوق الرسمي
يعني البنوك اقل من كده والسعر اللي بيتم
طب اوله في السوق همم
الموازي او الاسود اعلى من كده ال- همم في
صح واضح جدا في اتفاق مع صندوق النقد قطعا
قطعا قطعا قولا واحدا مش محتاجه خطوه انه
خلال ايام سوف يكون هناك تعويم جديد بمعنى
ان سعر البنوك هيعكس هيقترب ما بين همم
يعني اقترب من السوق الموازي شويه مش بنفس
الحجم المنفلت في الاسابيع الماضيه لكن
هيكون في تعويم جديد بالمناسبه لان انا
كنت متوقع
اسئله عن الاقتصاد المصري اللي هو بمناسبه
انه وقع مؤخرا مع صندوق النقد بمناسبه ان
في ازمه في الدولار بمناسبه همم
ان في بكره احنا النهارده 21 22 اول
اجتماع للبنك المركزي المصري واللي متوقع
انه يرفع الفايده بشكل كبير جدا ولما يرفع
الفائده يعني اثنين اثنين ونصف في المئه
وجاهز اكثر شويه من المتوقع ان ده هياثر
على امور كثيره الغلاء الاسعار الفائده
فانا سبقت الحلقه دي بتسجيل حلقه حوالي 25
دقيقه مع صديقنا هادي جديده واظن ان فيها
معظم الاجابات ان شاء الله بعد هذه هي
الحلقه سوف اضيعها علشان تبقى قبل قرارات
البنك المركزي المصري بكره مساء باذن الله
لماذا كل تحليلاتك عن السعوديه تتضح انها
خطا مع مرور الوقت نلاحظ هذا الشيء من
خلال متابعه فيديوهاتك القديمه انا مش
عارف تقصد اقول ايه لكن عموما انا مجتهد
انا ما اعرفش انت بتقول ايه هو اللي كان
خطا لكن انا في كل الاحوال السعوديه مصر
غيرها انا ابذل الجهد واحاول قراءه الموقف
في وقت
انت لما اي حد يعني ايه كلمه تحليل معناه
ان انت ما عندكش معلومه يعني انا مثلا لما
يقول لي بكره البنك المركزي هيعمل ايه انا
باشوف المعلومات بس تقسي بس الاصحاب
الخبرات لان انا ما بافهمش في كل حاجه انا
بافهم في موضوعات قليله واسد زيتي وزملائي
بيفهموا في موضوعات كثيره وده الفرق ما
بين الصحفي وما بين غيره يكون عنده مصادر
تقدر تساعده في فهم المعلومات وقراءه
المشهد ابن المجهود لقراءه مشهد في لحظه
ممكن اقول حاجه على السعوديه دلوقت او مصر
وتكون بدلته كل الجهد وتوفقت في القصه
ويبقى ده صح لمده اسبوع شهر شهرين تتغير
يعني دوام الحال من المحال هو في احد يعني
كثير كان متوقع مثلا في يناير اللي فات مش
يناير في اخر يناير وفي اول فبراير رئيس
دينيسقي نفسه رئيس اوكرانيا كان يستبعد
تماما ان يقوم الرز بالغزو وده راجل واقف
على الجبهه وبيتابعه وبيعمل ولم يتوقع شيء
همم لكن لو ادتني امثله ممكن نستفيد مع
بعض وانا ما عنديش مشكله خالص ان انا
اعتذر لو كنت اجتهدت في حاجه همم
اخطات فيها
ما رايك في التعوير الحاصل بين ايران
وروسيا في مستويات المتعدده ده تعاون
منطقي جدا لانه الاثنين باتوا منبوذين
خصوصا بانه في توتر خفيف ما بين الصين وما
بين ايران بعد زياره الرئيس
شيل الرياض والتقارب اللي حصل مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ودول مجلس الخليجي
ودو-دول دول الخليجيه الاخرى والدول عربيه
ومباركه الرئيس الصيني لبيان ختامي بيعكس
وجهه النظر العربيه تجاه جزر الامارات
الثلاثه طنب همم الكبرى والصغرى وهمم ابو
موسى همم
[موسيقى]
وراي دول الخليج يعني يعني واا ادانته
للانشطه النوويه الكلام ده ازعج
الايرانيين كثيرا على كل الاحوال ده مش
معناها ان في قطيع ما بين ايران والصين
ولكن معناها انه اقرب دوله الان الى ايران
هي روسيا الاثنين بيجمعهم الماذق واا يعني
الحصار الشديد الضغوط الدوليه الشديد
الشديده
لماذا روسيا والصين روسيا والصين وبقيه
الدول لا يعلمون لا يعملون كخطوات الممثله
ضد امريكا
اللي ممكن يتعمل ضد امريكا من اول محاوله
ضرب الدولار هما يتعاملوا معاملات ثنائيه
يعني دول البريكس الخمسه الصين روسيا
جنوب افريقيا
البرازيل
الدوله الخامسه
بدات ان هي تتعاون مع بعض فيما بينها على
مستوى متقدم بالعملات المحليه الصين بدات
تجري بعض المعاملات مع دول العربيه زي مصر
والسعوديه وغيرهم بعملات محليه همم
همم فبالتالي طائر على على مستوى
التحالفات ما انت عندك في تقارب بيزيد يوم
بعد يوم ما بين ايران وروسيا بالصين رغم
خلافاتهم ضد الولايات المتحده همم على كل
المستويات يعني على كل المستويات ده مش بس
كده ده حتى الدول العربيه ودول افريقيه
بدات تقول الولايات المتحده لا واكبر كلمه
لا كان رفدهم للانصيع للولايات المتحده ان
هم كلهم يقاطعوا روسيا وقالوا لها دي مش
حركات تكلفه يعني همم في الاسلحه فانا مش
خبير في الاسلحه لكن لي بعض الاصدقاء اللي
هم كانوا يعني مهتمين بصناعه الصواريخ واا
بيكلموني كثير عن تفوق روسي همم في اثناء
يعني صناعات عسكريه متعدده لكن انا لا
استطيع ان اجزم بماذا دقه كلامهم وكلام
كمان من خبراء الغربيين على العموم روسيا
دوله كبيره في صناعه السلاح وغيره دوله
بتواجه يعني كل الدول المتقدمه في العالم
تقريبا يعني مش محتاجه ان احنا نقول هي قد
ايه دوله قويه
هل ستباع قناه السويس صفاء انت لا تباع
لمين يا صفاء قناه السويس لا مش هتتباع
لماذا الجنس الاسود ضعيف لماذا البيض هم
المسيطرين دائما اليس هناك له علاقه لا ما
فيش لا ده سؤال سامحني يا يونس ده سؤال
عنصري جدا لا المساله لي علاقه
همم لو بتتكلم على همم اولا لو بتتكلم على
اصحاب اللون الاسود ما لهمش علاقه
بشهادتهم همم ولا اللون الابيض ولا كذا
همم ولا همم الصينيين ولا المساله مساله
تاريخيه انت بتتكلم على انه الدول الغرب
جاء دور التقدمه من 400 سنه ولا 500 سنه
وزرت مع الثوره الصناعيه كانت في فتره
انحدار
للمثلا للدول العربيه وللعالم الاسلامي
ودي دورات بالنسبه لافريقيا كانت بلد طبعا
بلدان كانت لسه لم تنمو كانت فقيره تم جذب
عدد تم جلب عدد كبير جدا من هؤلاء همم
كعبيد وده طبعا كان ممارسه موجوده في
العالم وقتها وبالتالي لما راحوا هناك ما
كانوش اصحاب ثروات ما كانوش مستثمرين ما
كانوش مبادرين ما كانوش حاجه فعاشوا في
الفقر
وورثوا اولادهم الفقر وبالتالي طبيعي انه
الراجل الابيض اخذ فرصته اكبر بكثير
وبالتالي الراجل اللي استفاد من جهد الرجل
الاسود مجانا لاولاده ثروه وتعليمه وهكذا
ما لهاش علاقه بالجين لها علاقه بالظروف
والتطور التاريخي
ربنا يخليك ويحفظك اياد بيقول كلمتين
حلوين شكرا جزيلا يا اياد ربنا يخليك هل
انتهت حرب امريكا على الارهاب عرفني ايه
هو الارهاب وانا اقول لك الحرب تخلص امتى
لانه امريكا بتعتبر كل دوله مختلفه معاها
على انها دوله مارقه ده تعبير لطيف دوله
مارقه عاوزه تضرب النظام الدولي وتهدد
السلم العالمي او تصفها بانها راعيه
للارهاب انتم كنتم فاكرين ان الكلام ده
يتعلق بالمسلمين قالت على
روسيا انها دوله راعيه للارهاب
على فكره يعني انا دايما الكلام في ناس
بيعتقدوا ان انا باقول ان انا بدعم الرؤوس
ولا بدعم الصينيين ولا انا واقع الامر
اللي بادعم الروس ولا الصينيين انا اكثر
انا ضد السياسه الامريكيه لاسباب وجهها
فعلا يعني يعني مهما بذلت جهد للتعاطف مع
الامريكان ومحاوله فهمهم انا ممكن اكلم
حضرتك من دلوقت لمده ثلاث ايام على جرائم
ما كانش لها مبرر ما لهاش مبرر من اساسه
واخرها الحرب الروسيه الاخرانيه فعلا كان
ممكن الحرب يمكن تجنبها بالاستجابه للطالب
بسيط ومنطقي للروس وان كان حتى هيحرم
الاقران او فئه من الاوكران من ان هم
يروحوا ل همم الاتحاد الاوروبي او ده ما
كانش في مشكله كبيره اكثر او يروحوا الحلف
شمال الاطلسي ده اللي هي المشكله الاكبر
لكن ده ممارسه مفهومه ومقبوله وتكلمنا
عنها كثير وده اللي بيحصل في كل حته في
الدنيا ان ما فيش دوله كبيره بتقول اللي
جنبها اعملي زي ما انت عاوزه امريكا لم
تسمح لها للعراق ولا نقوبه ولا فنزويلا
ولا كل دول امريكا اللاتينيه ولا
لافغانستان ولا للدول العربيه ان هي تعمل
اللي هي عاوزكم ولا للقاره الاوروبيه
هتعمل اللي هي عاوزها
في كلمه قاسيه مدلين دي كانت وزيره خارجيه
امريكا كلكم تعرفوها طبعا لما في صحفي كان
بيسالها في يعني همم 2000 وحاجه كده ان في
نصف مليون عراقي ماتوا من العقوبات
فقالت ذا برايس از ويرسلت يعني اللي احنا
حققناه يستحق ان احنا نضحي بالنص مليون
اللي انت بتقول عليهم دول ده حوار علني
كلام علني معلن يعني مش كلام
دلوقتي امريكا هتسمح بانتصار الروس وخلاص
مش هيتراجعوا يعني ايه حرب عالميه فعلا
ثالثه احمد جابر
والله اللي انا شايفه احمد حتى هذه اللحظه
انه طبعا الرز مش متراجعين يعني يعني
قطعوا الطريق على انفسهم لانه في 30
سبتمبر لما الرئيس الروسي ضم الاربع
مقاطعات اللي هي اوكرانيه
جمهوريتين
وخرسون واعتبرهم جزء من الاتحاد الروسي
وبالتالي بات عليه الدفاع عليهم عنهم قطع
نهايه المفاوضات فمستحيل انه يكون في
المدى المنظور في اي كلام عن حل اا حتى
نصف سهل خلاص
وبالنسبه للاكران مستحيل ان يجيء قائد
اوكراني مهما يعني ضرب انه يقول لشعبه انا
هاوافق على انه رؤوس ياخذ كل هذه الاراضي
انا مش شايف ان الامريكان رغم كل الخسائر
عندهم استعداد للتراجح حتى هذه اللحظه على
الاقل علنا لانه قبل ما ادخل على الهواء
كانوا بياكدوا مسؤولين ان هم قرروا اعطاء
صواريخ باتريت المتطوره للدفاع الجوي
لاوكرانيا
وقبلها بيومين حلف حلف شمال الاطلسي
والاتحاد الاوروبي تعهد بمزيد من
المساعدات مساله او اخذه في تصاعد وكل
واحد بيراهن من سوف يصرخ اولا
هل يكون لنجاح كاس العالم في قطر تاثير
على دعم المثليين مش شايف العلاقه يعني
المثليين لما زي ما انت شفت الحلقه كده
ماشيين على كل الصعود في محاوله الاقناع
العالم انه ايييي لنا حقوق يجب ان تكون
مقدمه على كل حقوق البشر
في حد بعث لي رساله عتاب وقال لي انت
دائما راجل همم محايد وانت يعني اضفت
اضافته لواحد من اخرين اللي بيهدمه
الاقليات الجنسيه انا ما هجمتش حد والله
لو في احد بيقول انا عندي سبب طبي لو
العلم بيقول انا مش عارف وانا لما عملت
حلقه عن حقوق المثليين كنت تحريص ان انا
لا اتطرق للكانب العلم اللي انا مش متخصص
فيه بس انا قلت مازلت اقول لو ان في علماء
بيقولوا ان في احد
مولود وعنده مشاكل يتم مراعاه هذه المشاكل
وتؤخذ في الحسبان زي المتحولين او في واحد
متحول العلم بيقول ان هو ولد راجل لكن هو
عنده جينات او عنده يعني المفروض يبقى
اقول انثى دي حاجه خلاص العلم اللي يقولها
مش انا
العلم القانون ينظموا العمليه دي انا اللي
انا يعني واخذ منه موقف انه الاقي اي حد
وفي الحل اللي احنا بنتكلم عن المثليين
مصر على انه يفرض على الباقيين خياراته هو
بس بالدراما وبالقانون وبالثقافه طب عاوز
اقول لحضراتكم على حاجه الناس اللي
زعلانين يعني اللي شايفين يعني محاصره
المثليه الجنسيه المفتعله امر مش مقبوله
اي واحد ينزل يعيش في الغرب او في
الولايات المتحده مثلا
بيتم السخريه منه جدا اذا كان يجمع بين
زوجتين وكثير من اللي بيتابعونا عايشين في
اوروبا انه عاوز يجمع ما بين زوجتين
وشوفوا ان ده شيء لا يعني بيحتكروه
وبيسخروا منه الناس اللي بتسافر مننا او
بيقيم هناك بيحترم القانون الغربي
اوكي مفهوم يبقى هو عاوز مني ان انا احترم
انه لعدم الجمع ما بين زوجتين لكن في نفس
الوقت هو عاوز هنا ما يحترمش ثقافه
كل شعوب الارض وثقافتهم في انه همم
عدم فرد ثقافه المثليه الجنسيه والقبول
بناس عاوزه ترفع عن نفسها لمجرد انه يعمل
همم يعني يعمل اكسبلورنج ل همم لمتعه
الشخصيه والهويته الجنسيه الجديده
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد وعليكم السلام راي
حضرتك في نزول الدولار اليومين اللي فاتوا
ده طبيعي انت بتتكلم على مصر واضح لانه
بعد توقيع قرض الصندوق مصر مع قرد الصندوق
واصول دفعه اولى حوالي 350 وهمم حاجه كده
مليون او 300 يعني حاجه كده في حدود 350
اقل من 400 مليون جنيه يعني دولار
على طول السوق بيبقى في حاله ترقب ده
معناها ان في فلوس ثانيه هتجيء معناها ان
في قرارات هتطلع معناها ان في سعر فائده
هيرتفع معناها ان في شهادات في البنوك
هتمتص السيوله من السوق
بيتوقعوا ان السوق هيتفتح للاستيارات
فبيبقى في حاله تراكم تجار السوق السوداء
بيترقبوا عشان ما يخسرواوش وبالتالي بتحصل
عمليه نزول
مازن
حسين اذا فشل الروس انا مش عارف ايه مفهوم
الفشل اذا فشل الروس في ايه بقى انت عندك
الفشل له تعريفات الروس اذا شعره عسكريه
يعني اذا فضل البوتن موجود وحتى الان
استطلاعات الراي في روسيا بتقول انه لا
يواجه اي مشاكل المخابرات الغربيه بتقول
لا يواجه اي مشاكل بتقول ان في غالبيه
هناك تؤيد الحرب لكنها ليست واثقه من
جدواها
فشل في ايه يعني حتى الان وهو بيسيطر على
الاقاليم الاربعه اللي اخذها وبيسيطر على
شبه جزيره القرم وبيسيطر على معظم الاجواء
الاوكرانيه فشل الروس لو هتسميه حتى الان
بيتمثل في انه لم ينجز المهم همم كما تخيل
الدول الاخرى وربما كما تتخيل صانع القرار
الروسي في وقت قصير وبخسائر قليلا
ايه اذا الامريكان اذا الغرب اعطوك كم
كبير جدا من الاسلحه يمكن ان يلحق بالجيش
الروسي
خسائر كبيره لن يتردد الروس في استخدام
مستوى اخر من الاسلحه ربما يبيد به كل
المدن الاخرانيه يعني اللي فيها مقاومه
حضور رئيس الصين للسعوديه هل يدعم دخول
السعوديه لبريكس عام يدعمه يدعمه طبعا وهي
مش ناقصها حاجه علشان تدخل الا لما تحسم
خياراتها طبعا فيما يتعلق بعلاقتها
بالولايات المتحده
ايه
بالرغم من حجم اختصارات الهند والصين الى
انهم معتمدين تكنولوجيا على الغرب هل تقوم
القوه العظمى على الاقتصاد من دون
تكنولوجيا لا صديقنا هونر اولا بالنسبه
للصين هي تطورت تكنولوجيا بسرعه مش عاوزه
بالغ يعني وبسرعه الضوء واصبحت هناك
تكنولوجيات في الصين تفوقت فيها على
الولايات المتحده والغرب وانا كنت اشرت في
حلقه لما كنا بنتكلم على زياره الرئيس
الصيني لعدد من الدراسات الغربيه اللي
بتشير الى ده وبيشير الى
تكنولوجيات محدده منها تكنولوجيا
التحول الى الطاقه الخضراء سن متفوقه فيها
جدا منها تكنولوجيا الجيل الخامس الصين
متقدمه فيها جدا في تكنولوجيات تفوقت فيها
الصين وفي التكنولوجيات الصين لسه لا جينغ
بخاند او لكن بتحاول الهند ااه
هي عاده يعني اقتصاديه يعني همم يعني
بتاخذ فتره طويله لاسباب يمكن ثقافيه
بتاخذ وقت كثير علشان انما ما يعني في وضع
همم تكنولوجي جيد تقدر عندها ما تقدمه
للاخرين وهمم بيت باي بيت او رويده ان
رويدا همم هيبقى في فرق يعني هيبقى
الادفانتج رايح في اتجاه الشرق
خصوصا مع العدد انت بتتكلم على حوالي 104
مليار و400 مليون وحوالي مليار و400 مليون
العدد بيفرق كثير يعني
رايك في السلام
السلام عليكم سيد هل امريكا قادره على
قتال الصين من اجل تايوان عثمان بن منصور
ما هو عثمان هذا هو السؤال اللي بيحير
كثير من الناس
يعني اا السؤال اللي شاغل صانع القرار
الامريكي انا اذا الصين دخلت تايوان
بالقوه هل ده يستحق ان انا
حرب على الصين واضمر العالم ولا ايه ده
سؤال الامريكان مشغولين به من من عشرات
السنين يعني وما زالت المساله غير محسومه
حتى الان انما اللي ما فيش شك فيه هو طبعا
لو اخذنا الكلام الرسمي قبل الرئيس بدل ما
فيش رئيس قال انا حارب علشان طيران دايما
المساله كانت بيضا قال ثلاث اربع مرات وكل
مره قال انا هاحارب من اجل تايوان طلع
البيت الابيض يقول لا تغير لسياسه البيت
الابيض وده ذله لسان او يعني
رايك في على فكره كان انا بحاول افتكر اسم
جوزيف ناي اظن ده استاذ علوم سياسيه شهير
في امريكا وكان عامل نظريه عن السوفت باور
او القوه الداعمه مره الصينيين بيسالوه
انتم هتحاربوا عشان طيران صحيح فقال لهم
نحن لا نعلم نحن الامريكان وانتم الصينيين
لا تعلمون يعني احنا ما نعرفش اذا كنا
هنحارب عشان تايوان ولا لا وانتم مش
عارفين اذا كنا احنا هنحارب او لا او انتم
هتحسموا امركم من تايوان امتى المؤكد ان
القرار الامريكي هتفرضوا اللحظه اللي هيتم
فيها الغزو الروسي ليه تايوان لحظه ساعتها
الظروف ساعتها الا طفره القرار
في تغيرات كبيره ودي عاوزه حلقه ما هو
اليابان النهارده تغيرت تغير كبير جدا
باصدار وثيقه جديده للدفاع عن امنها
القومي وبدات تتسلح من جديد وبدات تستعد
باسلحه هجوميه واحد الاسباب خوفها من
الصين ورغبتها في عدم غزو الصين لتايوان
لان اذا الصين غاز التايوان هتبقى قوه لا
يمكن وقتها وطبعا هيكون الهدف الثاني على
طول اليابان اللي بينهم خلافات حدوديه
لماذا الدول العربيه ليس لديها صناعه
عسكريه متقدمه مثل تركيا واسرائيل وايران
والله سؤال ده احنا عندنا صناعات ملابس
متطوره احنا عندنا مثلا صناعات اتصالات
متطوره ما هو البنيه التحتيه كلها
الصناعيه المتواضعه فما تسالش بقى عن يعني
الناس بيتكلموا عن التفوق الاسرائيلي مثلا
يقول لك اسرائيل عندها مخابرات الدعايه
الاسرائيليه عندها مخابرات قويه جدا وهي
طبعا عندها مخابرات قويه بس لما تيجي تحلل
مفيش هناك جنس بوند يعني ولا سوبر مان في
واحد قاعد على كمبيوتر في اجهزه التجسس
بيعملها علماء مش كوماندوز ولا همم يعني
ولا جيوش بتحارب بقوه يعني التفوق جاي من
العلم من الجامعات من المدارس التفوق اللي
موجود في ايران التفوق اللي موجود في
تركيا برده عباره عن تعليم افضل طبعا هم
بدرجات مختلفه وبالتالي علماء قاعده
الصناعيه وهكذا
احنا الصوت والصوره تماما تمام الحمد لله
وعليكم السلام ورحمه الله دكتور فارس طرحت
هذا السؤال في كل حلقه لم يتم الرد اديني
برد اهو يا ادم
هل يمكن ان تترجم الحلقات الى اللغه
الانجليزيه رجاءا شكرا على هذه القناه
الاكثر من رائعه ربنا يخليك يا ادم يعني
انا شاكر الاهتمامك بس
يعني انا الفكره بتطرح واخونا احمد بنده
صديقي همم اصدقائنا هنا في
الاستديو والمكتب بيتكلموا عن الفكره دي
بس همم عمليه مجهده جدا الحقيقه يعني لانه
همم يعني مش عارف مين اللي هيقوم بقوه
الترجمه انا لو عملت الترجمه
انما هي الفكره مطروح والله ان شاء الله
ربما يكون في ناس اصدقائي اتصلوا بي كثر
خيرهم حد ترجم حاجات للفارسيه حد ترجم
حاجات الى
الروسيه حد ترجم حاجات بس هو جهد الشخص
يعني وانا عارف مدى دقه اللي ترجموه طبعا
هل هناك قلناها خلاص
فشل روسيا معناها حرب ناويه هل توافقني
الى حد كبير نعم بس اصل الفشل المستويات
ما انت ممكن عندك موضوع كبير والله ما هو
ممكن الرئيس يعني لازم نحدد ايه الاهداف
عشان نقول ايه هو فشل في ايه
يعني ما هو ممكن في اي لحظه كان الرئيس
الروسي لما هو مش واثق من قدراته يقول
والله انا ضربت وجهت ضربه موجعه للجيش
الاوكراني ولم يستطيع ان يتعافى منها
وعلمتهم الادب وارجع كان ممكن جدا بس هو
ما عملش كده ده هو مش بس في شرق اوكرانيا
ده اخذ اخذ
بالاضافه لشركه اوكرانيا وخد خيرسون
واعلنهم ان هم جزء من حلف شمال الاطلسي
فهو يعني هو واثق انه ما فيش حل غير
المواجهه والمستمر في المساله فقولي لحد
ايه الاهداف هو في اي وقت ممكن يقول انا
حقيقه الاهداف بس هو شايف انه لا انا
محققتش وانا عندي القدره ان انا احقق ما
هو اكثر وان يتم همم ضرب كل احتمال
لمقاومه الاخراني
طبعا في النهايه اذا وجد انه عنده احراج
شديد وانه عنده خسائر كبيره ايه المانع
يستخدم النووي يعني انتم عارفين الامريكان
استخدامه النووي ليه في اليابان كانوا في
نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه لانه
اليابان مش عاوزه تستسلم كانت خسرت كثير
من يعني من الحرب اوفسيس يعني خارج حدودها
والحسابات العسكريه انه علشان اتاكد من
استسلام اليابان الحل ان انا ادخل حرب مدن
في المدن اليابانيه وبالتالي خسائر هتبقى
ضخمه جدا في الجيش الامريكي فكانت حسابات
القاده العسكريين وقتها ترومان كان هو
رئيس الولايات المتحده قرروا واظن الكتاب
اسمه تشايس كانت مذكراته وهو له جزئين
يعني كتابين سماهم
فقال احنا اخذنا قرار الضرب قرار الضرب
اليابان بالقنابل النوويه او بالقنبلتين
النوويهتين او نجزاكي علشان يضمنوا ان ما
فيش خسائر في الجانب الامريكي استسلام امر
ياباني
بخسائر ضخمه جدا بدون اي خسائر في الجانب
الامريكي فايه الغريبه انه الروس اذا شعره
من الخسائر تصاعدت انه يعني يسيروا على
خطى الامريكان ويضربوا مدن بالسلاح النووي
التكتيك الاقل عشان يقلله الخسائر في
جنودهم
ويعني احنا مش بنقول لكم ان ده حاجه كويسه
انا باقول لكم هم ممكن يفكروا كده
همم استاذ انت خارق
وانا بحبك والله انا قرات واعتقدتها شتيمه
بس كثر خيرك يعني لكن انا بقرا كل اللي
انا اعتقد ان انت بتقول ان انت اخرك يعني
لكن كثر خيرك انت كلمه كويسه انت كويس
وانا باحبك كثير
وما بتابع غيرك ولا قنوات ولا تشوف ولا
غيره لانك الوحيد
اللي حسبت اللي وجدته وحيادي عن جد وما
بتحط رايك او كميتك او دينك او مصلحتك
بالتحليل اللي ربنا يخليك يا احمد انا
هاروح البيت مبسوط ان ده رايك يا احمد كثر
الف خير
اخونا محمد بيقول ما هو مصير لبنان
والله المصير لبنان البلد يعني البلد ضاع
للاسف يعني عندنا صديقه لبنانيه صحفيه
ربنا يخليها ويحفظها يعني بتقول لي سيد مش
احنا افلسنا قلت لها اه
البلد خربت قلت لها قالت لي تفتكر
المسؤولين سايبنا اعمل لسه بيسرقونا لسه
بيسرق
كان الله في عون اللبنانيين
ما في شيء لبنان زي سوريا مش هيحصل ان هي
تفوق وتبقى كويسه او يبقى فيها امل الا
اذا حصل توافق توافق بين مين ومين توافق
ما بين ايران
وكل ما اعادها مع السعوديه ومع امريكا الى
اخره يعني
في رايك مشاكل الهويه موجوده في العالم
العربي بقدر اد ايه مشاكل الهويه مش فاهم
السؤال يعني عرب مثلا وامازيج
لو وضحت لي السؤال اكون شاكر
ربنا يخليك يا اياد كلام لطيف جدا السؤال
ممكن تشرح لنا سنريوهات سقف اسعار النفط
والغاز من المتضرر الاكبر وهل سينتصر
برايك في النهايه الغرب او روسيا في معركه
كسر العظام الاقتصادي والله السؤال ده
الطرح
على باشكال متنوعه وانا بدوري بطرحه كل
يوم على نفسي وعلى من اعلم يعني مين ينتصر
في المعركه المعركه طويله جدا انا مره قلت
في برنامج تليفزيوني من فتره انه
الامريكان بيستعدوا لحرب طويله فلما حد
سالني طويله قد ايه قلت له من ثلاث اربع
شهور الامريكان عملوا حزمه مساعدات
هتقدم لي اوكراني على مدار ثلاث سنين يعني
هم عارفين ان هم قدامهم حرب طويله
فلما يعني مقدم البرنامج بيقول لي طب
واحنا وكنا يعني يعني هل ده ممكن مثلا ان
حرب تستمر تلات سنين العالم يتحمل العالم
يتحمل او لا يتحمل عاوز اقول لكم معلومتين
اولا فكره ان في دول كبيره تحارب حقنه
سنوات طويله مش حاجه غريبه ابدا
وذكركم انه على المستوى الاقليمي العراق
وايران قعدوا ثمان سنين طب دي دول
الاقليمي طيب دول نوويه
الهند باكستان في حرب اونلاين اوف يعني
مواجهات موجوده وتوتر واربع حروف من سنه
47 فده موجود
دول صغيره موجوده من مطلع التسعينات
فانت عندك الصراع ممكن يستمر عندك الصراع
على ا ا تايوان من سنه 49 فبتستمر سنين
طويله جدا يعني ممكن تستمر كثيرا جدا
وتصبح مشكله مجمنه ده اولا الحاجه الثانيه
ان الصراع النهارده لو توقفت المدافع
تماما
لا يمكن ان يعود العالم كما كان قبل 24
فبراير ابدا ابدا ابدا
ودي قصه ممكن نتكلم فيها على المستوى
الاقتصادي على المستوى التكنولوجي على كل
المستويات لانه العالم بينقسم ب- همم يعني
بيقول يعني سور كبير بيفصل ما بين كتل
واضحه بتتشكل الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
من ناحيه وقوه اخرى بتبز على راسها الصين
ومعها روسيا ومعاها الدول المغضوب عليها
من الغرب على راسها ايران وفي دول اصلا مش
عاوزه تكون موجوده في الغرب لانها تشعر ان
هي منبوذه منه زي تركيه اللي اترفدت من
الاتحاد الاوروبي انا اكبر من ام ترفض
فاحنا عندنا عالم جديد بيتشكل وهمم اذا
توقفت الحرب النهارده المدافع بكره الحرب
لم تنتهي وهيبقى عندنا صراع طويل المزمن
وممكن اوكرانيا تبقى هي كشمير الجديده
اللي بتتخانق عليها الهند وباكستان
من اكثر من 70 سنه
في رايك سيد في قناه عبد الرحمن اشرف
بيقول قناه السويس انا مش عارف قصدك ايه
في قناه السويس لو قصدك قناه السويس
الصندوق الاستثمار الجديد
في ازمه الديون في مصر في حل غير بيع اصول
الدوله ولا عليه العوض لا ان شاء الله همم
يعني همم يعني في امل موجود من حوالي عده
شهور لما كنت بقول انه انا مش شايف الصوره
بالغه السوداويه لان الناس كانوا بيتكلموا
عن افلاسه وانهيار حد بيقول لي انت بتلطف
من المسائل مش بلطف والله انا قلت كلام
يعني يعمل لي همم يعني مش مقبول ولا حاجه
يعني انا لطفش من حاجه انا قلت كلام صعب
جدا وقلت ما اراه وما اعتقده بس لا ارى
ولا اعتقد ان البلد هتفلس على وش على وشك
الافلاس همم مش هتبقى سريلانكا مش هتبقى
غنيه مش هتبقى غني اسف مش هتبقى
لبنان لانه في بلاد بيقولوا عليها توبيك
توفيل دول كبيره صعب جدا ان العالم اصلا
يسمح لها بالانهيار ومسرح عندها يعني
ثروات ايوه هيكون في بيع اصول
والسنه الجايه 23 و24 و23 على واجهه
تحديدها تشمل بيع اصول كثير كبير كثيره من
الاصول المملوكه للدوله شركات وغيره
وغالبا هتبقى طبعا لمستثمرين اجانب علشان
ازمه الدولار
ويعني همم انت بقى شايف ان الاصول دي
معناها حاجه سيئه شايف انه ممكن تبقى اكثر
كفاءه مساله تحتاج الى جدال يعني لكن ان
شاء الله عندي امل انه الازمه تستمر تستمر
طبعا لفتره لكنها لن تكون عنيفه جدا واللي
بيخفف من واقع الازمه انه ما هيش حاجه
استثنائيه مصر في القصه يعني عندك دول
كثيره ظروفها همم صعبه لكن مصر واحده من
الدول اللي ظروفها صعبه جدا بلا شك
وبعدين برده الازمه تعدي
بشكل قصير كما اتمنى تطول شويه
في كل الاحوال الحاجه الدرس اللي احنا
عليه علامات استفهام هي قدره الحكومه اللي
موجوده والحكومه اللي فاتت والحكومه اللي
جايه ان هي تقدر العمليه صعبه اسمها ان هي
تقدر تحط يدها على بدايه الطريق اللي هو
فكره ان احنا نكون دوله اكثر انتاجا من
كنا دوله مستهلكه ونفس الكلام بينطبق على
دول كثيره زينا فيها مشاكل همم
هلا هيكون هناك تدعيات على دول الشرق
الاوسط من قبل الاداره الامريكيه بعد
زياره الرئيس الصيني للمنطقه هي لامريكا
تقدر عندها ايه تعملوا يعني امريكا
معندهاش حاجه غير انها تؤذي الناس يعني بس
يعني ما هي عملت كل حاجه ايه ممكن تعمله
يعني عملت كل شيء وبعدين هي اصل الدول
العربيه بتتحرك برده بكثير من الذكاء
الاقتصاباته
في صوره نبطيه كده ان الحكام والدول
العربيه ديت قليله الحيله هو عاجزه
وتابعها الكلام ده مش دقيق يعني الدول
العربيه دول الافريقيه الدول الناميه اللي
على راسها الدول الكبيره زي الهند اخذت
الدروس من عشرات السنين وبقت كلول طبعا
الدول دي مش كلها سياسه واحده بقت تحاول
تاخذ يعني تشوفها تستفيد ايه في همم لا
يعني هي لا هي بتستعدي امريكا ولا بتصل
معها زي ما القذافي زي ما صدام همم مثلا
وصل معها
ولا هي بتعمل زي الدول ثانيه في فترات
باعت كل حاجه وماشي معك وكل اللي انت
عاوزه بتحاول ان هي ما تستفزش الامريكان
الى درجه ان هم يعني اييي يحيق بها الاذى
يعني
ماذا لو لم يكن ربيع عربي برايك همم
بالعربي ما جاش يعني
مش عارف سؤال محتاج تفكير الحقيقي بس اللي
مش محتاج تفكير انه هو لغايه دلوقتي انا
يعني انا
باحاول افتكر اسم الاساسياله جيست
كنت قابلت في 2012 سياره عالم اجتماع
امريكي من اصل ايراني
واثر فيا جدا احنا تقابلنا يومين
اعداد طويله الحقيقه ولكن كان عامل كان
عنده رؤيه جميله جدا انا اسف الاسم مش
موجود في ذهني الان ولكن كان لفت نظري في
2012 يعني كان ربيع العربي يعدي عليه سنه
واحده انه هتعيشه سنين طويله في الفوضى
والعنف الشديد
وانه انتم مش هتخرجوا من الازمه دي قبل 10
15 سنه
لكن ده امثله كثيره بس يعني ما فيش وقت ان
احنا ممكن نتكلم عليها يعني لكن الحاجه
اللي اتمنى وصدقت رؤيته جدا
اتمنى اني باقي كلامه يصدق وانه الفوضى
اللي احنا عايشينها ديت هتبقى جزء في بعض
البلدان من بناء مراحل جديده نضج اكثر
للشعوب انا مش حتى الان مش شايف ده انما
اتمنى انه تصدق لكن على كل حال
سؤالك سؤال ضخم جدا واجابته القصيره انه
حتى هذه اللحظه ولا سنوات مقبله الاثر بشع
جدا
ما سبب ترديد جميع اجهزه وقنوات الاعلام
الغربي لنفس العبارات والحيازهم لنفس الصف
عند وقوع ازمه معينه
بالرغم من استقلال الاعلام عن الحكومه
ووجود مساحه من الحريات شوف بس انا حاسس
ان انجر اخذت الحلقه كلها ولا ايه اصل انا
ببصش على الاسئله
الاعلام كان صدمه الاعلام الغربي كان صدمه
في الازمه الاخيره بتاعه حرب اوكرانيا
لانه بقى عامل شويه زي الاعلام التعباوي
اللي هو اا عاوز يطلع الرؤوس على انهم
مجرمين بكل السبل واا يعني
حقيقه كانت صدمه يعني
فانما يظل بعد وسائل الاعلام فيها هناك
برده مساحه من الحريه اكثر في ناس
بتحاول ان هي تعمل عقلها اكثر لكن يعني هم
حاسين ان هما في حرب
وبيتصرفوا احيانا بشكل ايدولوجي يعني انه
احنا الخير وهم الشر وفي طبعا همم رجال
اعمال اا شركات كبيره بتملك وسائل الاعلام
برده بتسيطر عليه وبتفرد اجننتها لكن هو
سؤال الحقيقه يستحق الاحترام يعني او
يستحق التفكير كمان رايك في الصراع الصيني
الامريكي في افريقيا
رايك في على فكره
العودا على انجيلا انا بفكر دلوقتي انا مش
فاكر على مدار تقريبا ال 30 سنه اللي انا
اشتغلت فيها وكنت دائما بتابع اللي بيتكتب
يعني باللغه الانجليزيه اذا كان في الغرب
او في دول ثانيه
انه الغرب تحديدا
يعني كان الاتجاه العام انا ما بتكلمش على
كتاب ليهم مواقف هو دايما عنده نظره يعني
انه اي حد غيرهم هو متخلف وشرير
فيبدو فعلا وفي قصور يعني ان حد يعني يعني
مخهم ضيق جدا يعني
عامل زي حد صحته كويسه وبيفوز ببطولات في
العاب القوه وشايف واحد ربنا يشفيه عنده
اعاقه ولا رجل كبير في السن يقول له يعني
انت لازم تجري ولازم ااا تعدي المنشو
وبتاع انتم اصرفكم كويسه بس هم مش بيبذوله
قوي مجهود عشان يفهموا ظروف كل بلد وهي
بتتصرف كده ليه يعني الا النخب او العقول
الكبيره هناك ما هو الغرب مش كل عقول
كبيره يعني الغالبيه زي اي شعب بهم بسيط
وهمم يعني مش قادر يخرج بره الصندوق يعني
ايه رايك في الصراع الصيني الامريكي في
افريقيا في المستقبل وتاثيره على القاره
الافريقيه ممكن والله افريقيا تستفيد وانا
كنت عملت حلقه من حوالي سنه
سباق على افريقيا وقلت انه التاريخ
الافريقي عرف السكرانب الافضل
الدول افريقيا اللي بدا في القرن ال 19
وكان في سكرامبل تاني بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه في الحرب البارده
السرعه الاولاني ده اللي تقسموا في
افريقيا وكل دوله خارج جزء يعني
وبعد في الحرب البارده الاتحاد السوفيتي
والولايات المتحده
وبعدين بدانا في سكراب الجديد دلوقتي اللي
هو انه الدول بتبحث جائعه عن الموارد
والموارد موجوده في اماكن قليله منها
افريقيا ومنها القطب الشمالي ففي صراع في
القطب الشمالي وبرده احنا كنا عاملين
الحمد لله حلقه عن القطب الشمالي اعمله
سيرش في القناه عن كلمه القطب الشمالي
لانه هيبقى موضوع مطروح جدا على الساحه
الدوليه السبب الموارد اللي موجوده تحت
وبسبب موقعه وكذلك الموارد اللي موجوده
حتى الان الصين السابقه حتى الان روسيا
قدرت تنجح في انها تاخذ مواقع تخدم مصلحه
في افريقيا
وحتى الان امريكا بتدخل القاره بنصف رئه
فتوقع ان الدول الافريقيه او الدول
الافريقيه هيكون عندها القدره ان هي تساوي
على اللي يفيدها اكثر يعني
سؤالي ايه ده رضا بيدور حول الملف النووي
هل ستشهد تازم في الملف هناك ام هناك
بوادر حل الاجابه بالنسبه للحل مش واضحه
يعني المحل الملف محلك سر والرئيس بايدين
النهار ده كان بيكلم سيده امريكيه واضح من
اصل ايراني وبيقول لها ان القضيه ماتت
الاتفاق مات 2015 ومش هنقدر نرجع له مره
ثانيه همم وبالتالي هم بيراقبوا الموقف من
بعيد الامريكان
مش مش قادرين على فكره الحرب وبالتالي
مطمئنين شويه ان مخابراتهم معلوماتهم
بتقول لهم انه ايران بتنمي قدراتها
ولكن حتى الان لا تسعى ان هي تمتلك سلاح
ناوي طبعا الكلام ده ليس منطقيا يعني اذا
هي نمت قدراته بقى عندها قدره ان هي تعمل
الصواريخ وتسنى وتصنع الماده المطلوبه
لتصنيع القنبله فما الذي يمنع ايران لكن
يبدو انه امريكا
اللي عجزت عن الحل اللي هو الاتفاق النووي
اللي كان يحقق لها كل اللي هي عاوزاه بسبب
ضغوط اسرائيل بالدرجه الاولى والدول
العربيه بالدرجه الثانيه ما همم مش قادره
ان هي تواجه بقى انها تواجه نفسها بحقيقه
انه بما ان انا مش هاقدر انفذ حل سلمي بما
ان انا ما قدرتش انجح في تنفيذ الاتفاق
اللي كان هيمقني برده مش قادره تقول
لنفسها ان الحل هو الحل العسكري
فسيب المساله كده لغايه ما الازمه تحل
نفسها بنفسها والازمه مش هتحل نفسها
بنفسها
سؤال ماذا بعد زياره الرئيس الصيني احنا
اجابنا بس لو في نقطه محدده انا تحت امرك
السلام عليكم سيد جبيل مع احتمال قيام حرب
العالميه الثالثه الاحتمال قائم اكثر من
اي وقت منذ 19
و62 يعني
اللي هي
ازمه ازمه صواريخ كوبا او
خليج الخنازير ازمه
اقرب من اي وقت اقرب من اي وقت مضى ونسال
الله اللطف يعني
السلام عليكم سيد ما اعلم ان الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه صعب توقعها وما ستقول
اليه ولكني ارغب في معرفه توقعك الشخصي
وشكرا
مش عارف يا مروان والله انا بتهرب من
الاسئله اللي فيها توقعات
لانه
انا كلمت حضراتكم قبل كده عن نظريه ال ال
ال ال البجعه السوداء
اللي عملها الاقتصادي اللبناني الاصل
الامريكي الجنسيه نسيم طالب واقتصادي
وكان عمل دراسه على
توقعات في الاقتصاد ازاي الناس بتتوقع
وكان وجهه نظر درسته اللي سماها البجعه
السوداء
الازمات الاقتصاديه ما بتكررش نفسها
بالحرف الازمات الكبيره بتفاجئ الناس من
حيث لا تدري يعني ممكن تدرس تاريخ الازمات
الاقتصاديه وتتعلم من اخطاء الاخرين فده
يفيدك في الازمات الصغيره لكن الازمات
الكبيره بتفاجئت من حيث لا تدري ولا تحتسب
وسمى نظريته الباجعه السوداء لانه كان
لغايه القرن ال 18 تقريبا ولا حاجه كده
يعني كان الناس بيعتقدوا ان البجع كله
ابيض لغايه ما شافه بقى سوداء فدي كان شيء
غير متوقع فسمى نظريته بالباك على السوده
في ناس بيحبوا يطبقوا هذه النظريه على
قراءه التاريخ ان التاريخ يكرر نفسه نعم
بس في الاحداث الصغيره الاحداث الكبيره
عاده السيارات الحروب اللي همم
الهدوء احيانا بيكون بشكل غير متوقع
وبالتالي
ده حدث كبير يعني ممكن يتطور ازاي
او ينتهي ازاي في الغالب نحن ننتظر المج
على السوداء ولكن تقدير يعني لو صارت
الامور بهذا الشكل انه كل الاطراف هتكجن
على مع الضغط الشديد اللي هتتعرض اليه
القطارات سوف ترهق و الطرف اللي يرهق اكثر
واكثر هو اللي هيكون اقرب الى القبول
والتسليم بالواقع بالوضع الراهن وممكن
يتحول الصراع الى صراع مزمن زي كشمير زي
ارمينيا قدره بايجان زي الصراع الفلسطيني
وتظل الاوضاع على الارض لصالح يعني همم
اللي حسمها او اللي عنده الوضع الاقوى
عسكريا وطبعا مستحيل لو قالوا ان الرز
اجهدوا طبعا لكن مستحيل الغربي واصل دعم
لاوكرانيا
بهذا القدر الدعم المالي الضخم جدا جدا
جدا
مش عارف هيجيب الفلوس دي منين مع الازمه
الاقتصاديه اللي بتضربهم مع ازمه الطاقه
صعب جدا ان هم يستمروا لمده شتاء اخر
السلام عليكم حضرتك قلت خلاص مساء الخير
سيد جزيل الشكر على البث لو تكرمت انا كنت
سالت السؤال ده في الحلقه السابقه وانتظر
من حضرتك التفضل بالرد ما الذي سوف تخسره
الولايات المتحده لو تخلت عن اوكرانيا
الان فعلا محمود خالد انت سالت السؤال ده
اذا تخلت الولايات المتحده عن اوكرانيا
الان هيكون الخسائر التاليه
اول حاجه هتخسرها هي ثقه حلفائها فيها
اللي هي
وخصوصا الدول القريبه من روسيا لو فتحت
الخريطه هتلاقي روسيا ودائما ان هتحتاج
الى خريطه كذا خريطه لانه روسيا ضخمه جدا
بس لو فتحت حدود روسيا الغربيه هتلاقي دول
البلطيق التلاته اللي هي استونيو لادقيقه
الى اخره بولندا واوكرانيا والدول الاخرى
الملاصقه اللي هي كانت جزء من النفوذ
الروسي او الدول الدول اللي كانت تابعه او
تحت النفود الاتحاد الروسي دول في خوف
شديد من انه اذا روسيا انتصرت سوف تبتلعهم
يتبتلعهم عسكريا بغزهم يا همم تمارس عليهم
ضغوط شديده جدا يتمارس عليهم عمليه تخريب
وبولينج الى اخره وبالتالي هم بيستجيروا
بالولايات المتحده وبيسر له على ان الحرب
تشتعل على امل ان هم يستهدفه الروس ويقضوا
عليها
اذا تخلت الدول دي هي تفقد الثقه تماما في
الولايات المتحده دول اخرى زي المانيا تجد
انه مضطر ان هي لن تثق في امريكا وهتحول
ان هيبقى فيه وفاق بينها اكثر وبين الروس
اذا حصلت انه المانيا يتوافقت مع الروس
على قاره الاوروبيه السلام همم وبالتالي
بلاد المتحده هتفقد نفودها في اوروبا اذا
فقدت نفودها في اوروبا المساله مش تقتصر
على اوروبا هتختصر كمان على اليابان على
استراليا كل دوله من دول في هجمين او قوه
كبيره بتصيطر على المنطقه الصين بالنسبه
للاستراليا بالنسبه لليابان الصين برده
وكذلك روسيا كل الدول ديت هتقول انا كده
لا لم اعد اثق في ان امريكا ممكن تدعمني
في صراعي مع قوه مع الرؤوس او مع الصينيين
وبالتالي الدنيا هتتغير كثيرا
وبعدين في امور ثانيه ما في تفاصيل يعني
انتم بتتكلموا على مستوى الاستراتيجيك بس
يعني ما اوكرانيا دي بلد غني بالموارد
الموارد دي مين اللي هيسيطر عليها روسيا
يعني هتزداد قوه طب روسيا بعد ما تسيطر
بعد ما تخسر بعد ما اوروبا تخسر بعد ما
الولايات المتحده بعد الولايات المتحده ما
تتخلى عن اوكرانيا
وروسيا توسيطر عليها والدول الاوروبيه
تفقد الثقه في امريكا طيب هي روسيا هتبقى
صديقه للدول اوروبيه تبقى هتفضل في حاله
حواجز وشك وقلق لان الدول دي خلاص تبقى
تستسلم للرؤوس يا اما تفضل في حاله اعدائه
وخوف وروسيا اللي هتبقى خائفه من همم
محاولات جديده من الامريكان او الاوروبيين
في كذا سريع يعني ان هم يحاولوا الهجوم
عليها او يحاولوا اضعافها هتبقى اكثر همم
تقربا من الصين ومن ايران
الموارد الطبيعيه اللي كانت في اوكرانيا
اللي ممكن تروح اوروبا هتروح
روسيا ومن روسيا تدعم بها خلفائها الجدد
همم
على الرغم من ان باكستان هي راعي طالبان
الان العلاقات توترت بينهم في الفتره
الاخيره ما سر توتر العلاقه بينهم العلاقه
بتتوتر بين طالبان وباكستانوف
كونك ان طبعا باكستان
دعمت طالبان على امل انه طالبان الجماعه
السنيه بافكارها اللي هي يعني انا باصفها
لا تكاليف او متشدده وفي حد بيزعل لما
بقول كده بس ده يعني ده اخر حاجه عملوها
ان هم منعوا البنات منهم يتعلموا في
الجامعه على كل الاحوال كان وجهه نظر
باكستان انه وجود طالبان في افغانستان
هيحد من نشاط همم الهند اساسا الخارجيه
اللي باكستان تبص على طول للهند السياسه
الخارجيه للهند تبص
لباكستان ولا الصين
لكن مش معناه ان هم متوافقين على كل
المستويات الباكستان عاوزه توظف حركه
الطالبه لخدمه مصالحها لكن طالبات طالبان
جماعه اكتسبت خبرات وعندها افكارها
والتصوراتها وعندها دلوقتي بلد بتحكمها
وليها برده مصالح مش بتتطابق
فش تحياتي لسيد التحليل والاخلاق ربنا
يخليك سؤالي ماذا لو سمحت ماذا لو سمحت
سؤالي لو سمحت هل سنرى نهايه للدولار
كعمله عالميا قريبا
هل ذلك بعيد وما هي العمله المرشحه للحلول
المحلات في الوقت الحالي والعمله والعمله
ولا ايوان ولا يورو ولا لان الدولار
الدولار يعني في احسن حالاته الان امريكا
كمان لسه هي اكبر اقتصاد في العالم لكن
عشان الكلام
احنا بنتكلم في عمر البشر بنتكلم على 70
سنه اقل من 70 سنه كمان انا بتكلم من نقطه
البدايه بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
اقتصاد امريكا كان 45% تقريبا من الناتج
المحلي يعني كل 100$ العالم بيعملها 45%
لامريكا
الرقم 45 ده تقلص الى حوالي 24% تظل هو
الاقتصاد الاكبر لكنه تراجع بشكل كبير جدا
الصين اللي كانت اقتصادها اصغر من هولندا
اصبحت دلوقتي 18 تريليون واصبحت يعني كم
بقى كم ضعف يعني
اليابان كانت اقتصاد عظيمه اربعه ونصف
تريليون تقريبا زي ما هي من همم 20 30 سنه
الصين تضاعفت ل 18 تاريخ اليوم عشان ما
طولش عليك في الاجابه انه
تدريجيا بس لولي باتشولي الدولار يتراجع
وده اللي احنا كنا بنقوله في اول حلقه
يتراجع نسبيا لان بقى في اليوان بقى في
اليوان دخل حتى في عمله احتياط بالنسبه
لصندوق النقد بقى في ناس تتعامل بالالوان
لانه عنده استعداد انه ياخذ اليوان على
مستوى الدول او التجار لانه يشتري به حاجه
وبدات الدول تستغنى تماما في معاملتها زي
روسيا والصين مؤخرا الهند بقت روبيه في
مقابل الروبل الص- ال- ال-
الروسي وبالتالي تدريجيا ممكن 30 40 50
سنه يحصل تغيير كبير
نا السؤال ده
رايك بالوضع السياسي في العراق والله ده
عاوز حلقه يا اخويا والله العظيم اخونا
حسين لان خصوصا بعد مؤتمر بغداد الاخير
يعني ولكن حتى الان يعني لو عاوز اجابه
قصيره
العراق لا حول ولا قوه حتى هذه اللحظه
العراق بيحاول يلاقي نفسه عنده صرع كبير
جدا على ارضه ما بين ايران ضد تركيا ما
بين ايران ضد الدول الخليجيه ما بين ايران
ضد امريكا
يعني ارتفاع اسعار البترول حسنه اوضاعه
قليلا في الفتره الاخيره
والاجهاد والضغط الايراني
اللي فيه السيد مقتدى الصدر خلى في حاله
هدوء نسبي
الاجهاد اللي عند حركه اكتوبر من الشباب
خلايا يائس يعني مش لاقي حد ممكن يعني
يعبر عن افكاره ففي حاله هدوء نسبي انما
الدوله هشه وضعيفه و
[موسيقى]
يعني برده زي ما تكلمنا على لبنان وتكلمنا
عن سوريا انه التطور في العراق مش هيجي من
جوه بقدر ما هيجي بعد توافق دولي من القوه
حلو مشكله ايران وكثير من المشاكل اللي
هتتحل في المنطقه بس حل مشكله ايران صعب
جدا جدا جدا
اليست المؤسسات الرياضيه الكبيره مستقله
اذا لماذا تصرفت جمعيه جميعها بنفس
الطريقه وتدخلت بالسياسه عند وقوع اول
ازمه وكانها تابعه لحكومه الماء تقصد
الفيفا يعني ولا تقصد ايه
هل يستطيع العالم التوحد تحت رايه واحده
وما هي الظروف
هل تستطيع دول علم التوحد تحت رايه واحده
وما هي الظروف التي تستطيع توحيد كل البشر
وتوقف الحروب في كل العالم والله ده ممكن
في اا حتى جمهوريه افلاطون كان فيها تقسيم
طبقي قاسي يعني ده
مستحيل هذه امنيات انت رجل يعني طيب القلب
فتتمنى امنيات
مستحيل تتحقق على الارض
برايك موقف الصين حاليا من الوضع في
اوكرانيا
الحركه كلها على الارض بين الناس في نفس
الاسره في نفس القريه في نفس البلد في ناس
كلها ايام على الصراع تناقد اللي انت
عاوزه غير اللي انا عاوزه فمستحيل يكون في
السلام اللي انت بتقول عليه
شكرا جزيلا على الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
اثرت بالسلب ام الايجاب في الملف الايراني
بالشرق الاوسط وكذلك في مفاوضات السلاح
النووي الحرب الروسيه الاخرانيه
همم
يعني غيرت اولويات الولايات المتحده
عقدت الملف لكن حتى لو ما جاءتش الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه اسرائيل ودلالها على
الولايات المتحده ما كان لها ابدا ان تجعل
الملف يمر انا في رايي وده كلام بيزعل
طبعا يعني صعب ان المسؤولين قلوب بس انا
مش مسؤوله انه الولايات المتحده ليس لها
مصلحه في تعطيل الاتفاق هذا الاتفاق تم
قتله لصالح اسرائيل وانا في رايي ان
امريكا عملاق
تجره اسرائيل من انفه حين يتعلق الامر
بمثابه بالشرق الاوسط
اولويات امريكا كثير منها في الشرق الاوسط
هي اولويات الاسرائيليه
من فضلك حلقه خاصه عن الفضه مع صديقك هاني
واتمنى حلقه خاصه عن الاقتصاد الرياضي لا
ما نعرفش في الاقتصاد الرياضي فموعدكش لكن
ممكن اوعدك بمساله الفضه
ماشي حاضر
احنا هنتفرج على الرياضه كل انواع الرياضه
استاذ سيد هل من الممكن ان تشرح لنا سبب
تخوف روسيا من دخول اوكرانيا الى حلف
الناتو مع ان استونيا ولادفيا تتشارك
الحدود مع روسيا ده سؤال جميل يا محمد
روسيا ما كانتش عاوزه ولا دوله
استونيا ولا اي دوله ولا بولندا ولا ولا
اي دوله تدخل حلف شمال الاطلسي وده كان
الاتفاق قبل تفكك الاتحاد السوفيتي في اخر
واحنا تكلمنا ده على حلقات كثيره وكان وعد
الولايات المتحده على لسان جيمس بيكر وزير
الخارجيه نطوا انش خارج المانيا الشرقيه
وذكركم تحدي كانت اقرب نقطه لالتقاء الغرب
بالشرق اللي هو الاتحاد السوفيتي والغرب
كانت المانيا المانيا الشرقيه مع الاتحاد
السوفيتي المانيا الغربيه مع القتل
الغربيه مع التطورات اللي حصلت وسقوط حائط
برلين سنه 89 بدا الغرب يتفاوض مفاوضات
مستفيده مع الاتحاد السوفيتي اللي كان
ترامب يانهار ادينا بس نوحد الالمانيتين
دول ادينا المانيا الاتحاد
هيطلع لكم كلام حلو قوي الوعد اللي ابتلعه
اتحاد السوفيتي ابتلع الروس بازاجهم لانه
كان ضعفاء يعني
اقتربوا مشوار انس انتقلوا مئات الاميال
وضمه كل الدول اللي انت بتقول عليها بس
اخر دول ضمها الدول الثلاثه اللي انت
بتقول عليها ده كان في 2004 وكان الروس
غارقين في توابع حرب الشيشان الثانيه
وكانت روسيا خارجه من المشاكل كثير لا حول
لها ولا قوه فما قدرتش تعمل حاجه ابتدت
تتحرك بدايه من 2008
يعني هي كانت مشغوله الاول في ان الشيشان
تفضل جزء من روسيا في الوقت ده كان الغرب
استغل الفكره وضم دول منع دول المنطقه
الثلاثه اللي هي قريبه جدا من من الرؤوس
2008 يحب يدوم جورجيا كان ابتدى يتعافى
شويه وعمل حرب الايام الخامسه ومنع القصه
ديت
2013 و14 عملوا اللي هي الثورات الملونه
حب اوكرانيا حصلوا النظام شبه جزيره القرد
تطورت المساله فدخل في 2000 22 الحالي هو
لا هو خائف جدا ورافض جدا بس ما كانش عنده
القدره
لمقاومه الضغوط او الرغبه الامريكيه
احسنت يا استاذ سيد كل سنه وانت طيب ربنا
يخليك ويسعدك ده يا محمد هلال
اخونا اياد هل تتوقع حرب قريبه في بحر
الصين الجنوبي او تايوان والى متى ستبقى
المعركه مؤجله برايك
يعني ما هو ده برده من ضمن الاسئله اللي
كنت بتكلم فيها في الاول الصين في رحله
صعودها بتحاول ان هي تتعلم من درس المانيا
ودرس همم لالمانيا تحديدا واليابان ان هم
يتحدوش القوه القائمه الا لما تكتمل
ادواتهم وبالتالي الصين بتنتظر وبتعد
العده
وفي احتمالين للحرب سمعت حاله في حالتين
حاله ان هي تبقى قويه جدا
وتقرر ان هي في وضع قوي وده احتمال مفهوم
لكن كمان ممكن تحارب لو ضعفت يعني اذا حسد
بالخطر وان هي الخطر هيدامها وان هي في
هتبقى في وقت من الاوقات اضعف مما هي عليه
وبالتالي ممكن تقرر الحرب لاسباب
الاقتصاديه والاسباب السياسيه بس دي قصه
يطول شرحها يعني
لماذا كل التحليلات احنا تكلمنا على
السعوديه
ماذا في راي حضرتك من هو الصحفي العربي
الذي يمكن اعتباره خليفه لمحمد حسنين هيكل
محمد حسنين هيكل عنده تجربه استثنائيه
لانه
على فكره في ناس لما تمدح حد تقول له انت
محمد حسنين هيكل واسف يعني لما تحب تهاجمه
تقول له انت محمد حسين هيكل انا رايي ان
ده ما تحلى لكن انا بالنسبه لي هو كان
شخصيه استثنائيه رغم انه حتى لما تختلف مع
مواقفه حتى لما تشكك في بعض رواياته حتى
لان هو في الاخر الكمال لله يعني انا
باتكلم على قدره الاستثنائيه ان هذا الرجل
ظل الى اخر يوم في حياته وعنده قدره على
تحريك الاحداث
حد صعب ان في احد يبقى زيه لان ده كان
عنده اكثر من هات اكثر من قبعه كان صحفي
استثنائي كان مسؤول وصل الى وزير خارجيه
ونائب رئيس وزراء بس المشكله مش في
الالقاب المشكله في انهي فتره الحاجه
الثانيه انه كان دائما قريب من كل دوائر
القرار بحيث دوائر القرار كلها مش بس عبد
الناصر كان عبد الناصر باعتباره كان في
اوجل يعني النفوذ المصري وبالتالي وبطلع
على الوثائق في كل مكان فكانت حلقه
استثنائيه لا ما فيش احد زيه ابدا ابدا
ما هي الاسلحه الروسيه ما اعرفش الاجابه
على السؤال ومش فاهمه هل سينجح التحول
لنظام عالمي جديد انا اسف يا اخونا رن
يعني ريمون انا مش فاهم السؤال يعني انت
بتتكلم على حاجه فنيه في الاسلحه ما فهمش
فيها هل سينجح التحول للنظام
لنظام عالمي جديد اقتاب اخرى
مع بقاء امريكا دوله عظمى ام ستنجح امريكا
في فرد رؤيته الخاصه والاحتفاظ بهيمنتها
ما هو الاجابه على السؤال ده هي اللي همم
اللي الناس بتدور عليه ان هي امريكا بتسعى
ان هي تحتفظ بقوتها وسيطرتها وتضعف الدول
الاخرى حتى ولو كان على حساب حلفاءها في
اوروبا والدول الاخرى عاوزه يكون لها مكان
تحت الشمس الصراع ده همم لا تحسبه السنين
اللي جايه يعني همم
احنا نقدر نشخص الصراع نقول هينتهي ازاي
ده فوق طاقه البشر يعني
ما رايك في رسم مصر للحدود البحريه مع
ليبيا لوحدها سؤال محتاج ان الواحد يبحث
فيه اكثر
ما عنديش اجابه حاضره
هل من المنطق ان يتراجع العالم عندهم
السابقه لبشار الاسد ويعيد تقبله كرئيس
شرعي ويتعامل معه وكان شيئا لم يكن
هو ده بيحصل في بلاد كثيره الحقيقه يعني
فكره انه اصل يعني فكره العداله اللي
بيسموها الدفاعي رايت او العداله يعني انه
همم ما بتتحققش يعني لا وبعدين السياسيين
في كل مكان في العالم الظروف بتمنعهم
القدره على الافلات من همم من كثير من
تصرفاتهم لان هم بيتحطوا في مواقع يعني
ايه احيانا
بيرتكبه جرائم همم
وعلشان الحياه تسير لازم يتم تجاوزها مش
بشار الاسد فقد بشار الاسد وسياسيين
كثيرين في العالم العربي طبعا ده معناها
انا مش باقول لك انه مش عاوز ادخل في
مساله التوصيف اللي عمله جرائم لان في ناس
بيقولوا اللي عملوا جرائم وفي اخرين
بيقولوا هو ما كانش عنده حلول اخرى انا مش
عاوز ادخل في هذا البيت ولكن اذا سلمت
بكلامك
ما فيش سياسي واحد كان في موقع خطير وموقع
مهم وفي اداره في تاريخ استثنائي الا
وتورت في جرائم خطيره انا لسه كنت اكلمك
عن مادلين والبرايت والساسه الامريكان
اللي بيقولوا ان قتل نصف مليون عراقي
مساله مبرره وتستحق ما تحقق من الحصار
العراقي يستحق همم
اه ممكن
اين ترى مستقبل الشرق الاوسط خلال العام
العقد القادم
10 سنين كثير للرؤيه ولكن واضح ان احنا
قدام حرب بارده جديده ما بين معسرين
وهنرجع ثاني لفكره انه الدول دي بتدير انا
اعتقد يعني المنطقه اللي هي تكون في ظروف
احسن لانها تحاول تستفيد من صراع القوه
الكبرى عليها بس بعد ما استفادت بقى من
تاريخ الحرب البارده اللي بدات من 47
لغايه 91
هل تعتقد ان الخلافات الخارجيه القطريه
سترجع بعد انتهاء كاس العالم لا مش هترجع
دلوقتي خالص هتحتاج وقت طويل جدا اذا رجعت
اشك ناس تتعلموا الدرس حتى الان يعني ممكن
ترجع خلافات اخرى مش بالضروره بين قطر وكل
دول الخليج لا
انا هاستاذنكم احنا فاضل لنا بدع دقائق
احنا بقى لنا ساعه ونص تقريبا
اا
احنا قدامنا اسئله كثير ثانيه
هل تعتقد ان الخلافات اصل هو من دو نام
وسبني انا
هل تعتقد ان الخلافات الخليجيه الان
من فضلك حلقه خاصه عن الفضه حاضر
الاقتصاد الرياضي لا افهم فيه ما افضل
الكتب كلمنا عنها ما رايك بتحركات الروس
العسكريه اليوم وهل اصبحنا على مقربه من
حربات الروسيه انا طلعت حلقه
24 ساعه يعني من حوالي امبارح يعني بتكلم
فيها عن التطورات اظن ان هم عسكريا افضل
على الارض بعد ما تخلوا عن وهم العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه وبداوا فعلا يستخدموا كل
يوم اقرب الى حرب شامله الدمار هيكون عنيف
جدا ممكن سياسه الارض المحروقه
ممكن تدخل اسلحه اكثر شراسه الخوف كل
الخوف انه
السياسه دائما بيدخلوا الحروب عندهم قدره
ان هم هيسيطروا على مجرى الامور الامريكان
معتقدين كده البريطانيين معتقدين كده رئيس
الفرنسي قال حاجه بتعبر عن الكلام ده
امبارح امبارح اللي هو 20 ديسمبر بيقول
انا هادعم اخرى بشارتين
الشرط الاولاني انه همم
الا يؤثر ذلك عن الامن القومي الفرنسي
يعني ده همم ما ياثرش على قدرته على
الدفاع عن نفسي الامر الثاني ان انا ما
كنتش طرف في هذه الحرب مباشر معنى كده ايه
يعني انا هافضل ادي اسلحه في الحدود اللي
اقدر عليها انا وغيري وكذا هو معتقد انه
كده الامور هتكون امنه ممكن تيجي في فتره
والامور لا تكون امنه صاروخ ينضرب هنا
صاروخ ينضرب هناك الرئيس يقوله احنا كده
بنضرب الاسلحه اللي بتدخل اوكرانيا لما
بتدخل حدود اوكرانيه بس لما بسمع لها
بالدخول بيكون قدرتي على همم
ضرب كل صاروخ بيدخل وهي كميات مهوله جدا
محدوده وبالتالي ممكن ان توجه ضربات الى
دول تابعه الحلف شمال الاطلسي يعني القدره
على ان الحوار
الصراع السيلوفر على خارج اوكرانيا كبير
ممكن تصرف من الجيش الاوكراني ممكن اي
حاجه
ما هو افضل سيناريو بالنسبه لنا
كدول عربيه
انتصار روسيا ام الغرب
والله احنا كدول عربيه احنا الدول العربيه
مش كتله واحده يعني كل واحد له مصالح
انما انا بيتهيا لي انه
مش عارف الاجابه على السؤال
ولكن انا ما اعتقدش ان احنا هنستفيد قوي
اللي انا شايفه يعني اذا اذا الولايات
المتحده انتصرت فهي
هتكرر فكره استفزازها للرؤوس اكثر
وهتكررها ممكن مع اخرين وبالتالي العالم
هيكون كله توتر اذا روسيا انتصرت النظام
العالمي كله برده بيتغير يعني فنلاقي
نفسنا قدام حاجه صعبه علينا ان احنا
نتخالها
لكن احنا متضررين من استمرار الحرب على كل
حال
لماذا لا تقوم امريكا باشعال جبهات اخرى
لاضعاف روسيا مثل لما هي عملت اشعار لكل
حاجه يعني لا تترك مكانا للولايات المتحده
الا وتشعلوا يعني ليبيا مشتعل هي ليبيا
هادئه يعني هي سوريا
شايف ان هي بتحضر بالسلام التقارير بتقول
انه يعني
سته من كل 10 سوريين مهددين بالجوع الجوع
يعني مش بنتكلم بقى على التعليم ولا كده
فيعني همم وطبعا هي بتضغط على كل الدول
الاخرى ان هي لا تضع لا لا تضع يعني بريك
واحد او طالب واحد في سوريا والا العياده
الحق به عقوبات
هو يعني لو انت بتسال انا اسفه السؤال
بتاع الرئيس السوري رجع مره ثانيه يكون من
المثالي جدا جدا انه الرئيس بشار الاسد
بيقول للناس
انه عند هذا الحد
انا اترك
المنصب لغيري يعني
وبالتالي وممكن حتى يتوافقوا على شخصيه
ويضمن هو يعني خروج امن وهكذا يعني ليه
والاسرته اذا عمل كده حقيقي يكون اذكى
كثير لبلده يعني بس ده كلام يعني مثالي
جدا انك انت لو حطيت نفسك مكانه صعب ان
انت تتخيل لو انت اصلا معتقد اولا دائما
الواحد معتقد ان هو مفيد بس حتى لو هو
معتقد انه هو مفيد او غير مفيد فكره
واسيب المرحله دي لغير غيرها هيبقى في
مشكله ثاني اولا هو لا يامن على نفسه
المشكله الثانيه
في مشكله غير لا يامن على نفسه يعني
مشكله الاولانيه انه ما فيش البدائل
الجاهزه وده في معظم الدول اللي ما فيش
فيها تداول سلطه وبالتالي توقع فوضى اعنف
من اللي موجوده اثنين ان القرار ده لن
تسمح به الدوائر الحاكمه اللي هي بتحكم
سوريا مع الرئيس بشار الاسد ما فيش رئيس
بيحكم لوحده ولا تسمح به قوه مؤثره موجوده
في سوريا لانها بنت تحالفات مع النظام
القائم اللي بيمثل الاسد فاذا ذهب الاسد
لازم يجي واحد زيه بالضبط بس انا معقده
جدا وبالمناسبه الرئيس بشار الاسد يعتبر
من وجهه نظر مصالح دول الخارجيه افضل خيار
موجود يعني هو الافضل للرؤوس الافضل
للايرانيين الافضل الاتراك في الوقت
الحالي الافضل للامريكان الافضل
للاسرائيليين
يعني افضل لكثير من الدول ليه بس دي مساله
يطول شرحها يعني
على فكره في حلقه لماذا يتودد الجميع
للبشار الاسد الان ممكن ترجعه لها فيها
جزء من الاجابه
احنا يعني انتهينا من الوقت في اسئله
كثيره
انا مش عاوز اتعب الناس اكثر من كده
اسئله قد ايه تاني
طيب نحاول نجاوب اكبر على الثاني ممكن على
السريع كده
انا مش عاوز اسيبكم والله بس انا بشعر بحس
انه كثير جدا جدا يعني بحس انه هتبقى
عمليه مرهقه لكم فانا هاحاول علشان اجاوب
اكبر عدد ممكن اجاوبه هل تعتقد ان ان
تتقارب السعوديه وايران الى في الوضع
الراهن ويتحالفها مع الصين الاجابه
مستحيله
التنقدات كثيره بين السعوديه وايران وحتى
لو هما ذللوا بعد
التناقضات في الثقه كل طرف بيعتقد ان
الطرف الثاني بيحاول اضعافه وهذا صحيح ثم
انه همم هم عندهم مشاكل برده يعني الصين
لسه اول ما ابتدات ان هي تلعب سياسه
خارجيه الثلاثه تاخذ اطراف
الخليج ضد ايران الصين لما تبتدي تدخل في
الفراغ اللي ساب امريكا هتبتدي تدخل مش
الدوله المقبوله من كل الاطراف
ايه الزياره الاخيره دي تترك اثر على
تصورنا للدور اللي ممكن تلعبه في الشرق
الاوسط
سيناريوهات مصر وليبيا وتركيا في ترسيم
الحدود وهل هناك خطر مواجهه مع تركيا
والله ما اعتقدش انه تركيا رئيس التركي
بيدور على بيسموها ايه ليتل سبلاندو دور
تعبير كده ايه بيدور على حرب صغيره رائعه
تعزز تعزز حظوظه في الداخل لكن مستحيل
يفكر عشان ينجح في الانتخابات على المدى
القصير مستحيل يورث نفسه اكثر حاجه ممكن
يورط نفسه فيها صراع محدود في شمال العراق
شمال سوريا اللي هو اظهره كرجل حامي لحدود
بلده لكن ما يورطوش في صراع مع دوله كبيره
زي مصر ولا معي ايران ولا لا مش هيحصل ده
يعني ده معناه انه هيفضل متورط في السنين
ايه
السلام عليكم سيد قبيل مع احتمال اجابنا
هل تتوقع اعلان حرب شامله على اوكرانيا
حسب العقيده العسكريه المحدث انا اعتقد ان
الحرب الشامله بدات
هل انتهت قضيه سد النهضه راضيه مصر بالامر
الواقع ما فيش حلول جزريه لكن لها لا لم
ترضى وهناك تحركات على صعد مختلفه
في حدود معلوماتي الصغيره يعني لكن
المساله طبعا اصبحت اكثر تعقيدا جدا جدا
مما كان متوقع لها
هناك تصريحات يقال انها حول تقسيم
اوكرانيا السؤال هل مازال كيسنجر له ثقل
انبات مهمل لا ليس له ثقل هو بس لانه
شخصيه عامه كبيره رايه لن يؤثر في شيء
وبعدين ال ال مش كلام يقال هو فعلا كده هو
كل اللي قاله بالضبط بالضبط ان انا بقترح
ان الروس يرجعوا الى حدود 23 فبراير يعني
يخرجوا من المدن اللي سيطروا عليها وعلى
فكره في علامات استفهام لان قبل 23 كان
الرسمه موجودين من خلال
دولتين لها نسك ولوجا نسك لكن دي يعني قصه
ثانيه
هنفترض ان ما فيش غموض وهو في غموض بس لا
احد يقترب من شبه جزيره القرم التي ضمت
سنه 2014 لان اذا حد اقترب منها سوف تكون
مواجهه بين روسيا والغرب ده اللي قاله
هنريكسسجن يعني بيطلب منهم الحد الادنى
انه
امنوا تمام
شبه جزيره القرم العالم ما اعترفش الدنب
روسي اعترفوا بها عشان تقنعه الرز بالجلوس
للتفاوض معكم وطبعا جزء من التفاوض انه
اوكرانيا ما تنضمش الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
رايك في الصراع الصيني الامريكي في
افريقيا في المستقبل وتاثيره على القاره
السمراء
انا اجابته
في نظرك من يتوفر على دعم دوري اكثر في
قضيه الصحراء المغربيه بين المغرب
والبوليساريو المغرب يحصى بضعم اكبر بكثير
جدا من البوليساريو وقدره ان هي تحقق
انجازات كبيره في الفتره الماضيه
همم
ايران وامريكا خدعه كبيره فهم كالاخوه ولا
يوجد شيء اسمه عداء معاه حتى مع الكيان
انا مختلف معك شكلا وتفصيلا يثبت العداء
بين ايران كبير جدا انا هل سيتم السؤال
الاخير هل سيحدث ان يتم تعديل الدستور
الياباني ويتم تطوير الجيش انا ما اعرفش
تعديل الدستور دي مساله تبقى همم يعني
دراماتك لكن في ظل وجود الدستور حدث انه
الروس قرروا اليابانيين قرروا تغيير
سياساتهم واستراتيجيتهم واعتبروا ان روسيا
والصين خطر وتهديد لهم وبداوا في تطوير
اسلحه هجوميه وتطوير قدراتهم العسكريه همم
معلش انا اسف سوف اكتفي بهذا القدر انا
شاكر جدا جدا لكم انا عارف انه ما زالت في
عدد همم كبير من الاسئله بس سامحوني لانه
الوقت طال ان شاء الله لو التجربه اللي
احنا عملناها لانه مشكورا صديقي احمد
ماندو يعني ساعدني هو والزملاء ان احنا
نطلع بكاميرا عاديه فاذا كان الصوت
والصوره تجربه ناجحه ممكن نحاول نخليها كل
اسبوع وتبقى مثلا ساعه كل اسبوع ساعه
واحده او اقل قليلا بس المنتظمه اسبوعيا
لو انتوا شايفين ان ده مقبول اكتبوا لي
بس يكتبوا في التعليقات برده عشان اه يعني
اكتبوها اكتبوا في التعليقات انه ان ده
مقبول ان انتم حبني كل اللي عندنا لقاء
اسبوعي مباشر نتكلم فيه بنفس الطريقه ديت
كده اذا وجدتم ان هذا مفيد ربنا يخليكم
ويسعدكم حلقه الاقتصاد المصري اللي
بتسالوا عليها هتكون موجوده ان شاء الله
النهارده متاخر يعني همم بحيث تشوفوها
النهارده متاخر او بكره وانا شاكر وممتم
جدا واتمنى لكم عام سعيد همم تتحقق فيه كل
الامنيات باذن الله اشكركم على اللقاء